Okay. Hey everyone, it's Michael Baltos
from Orderflows and this is the
Orderflows market analysis for Thursday,
June 22nd,
2017. The market was pretty uneventful
today. Jobless claims came out and it
did edge higher but not by very much and
it remains consistent with the very
strong demand for labor. The like I said
the markets were in a very narrow range.
S&Ps were pretty much unchanged. Oil
which has been on the back foot recently
actually posted a slight gain near
$42.75 and dollar index and currencies
were you know pretty much unchanged as
well. So um you know that said you know
let's take a look at the market but
before I do go through the
disclaimer this presentation is for
educationalformational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any other type of investment
decision. Futures train contains
substantial risk and is not for every
investor. An investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment. Risk capital's money that
could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle.
Only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading.
Past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results. Don't uh trade with scared
money and don't trade with money you
need to pay the bills. The tools I use
in this presentation are the order flows
trader and the delta sculper which is a
neat little uh tool we developed to help
analyze the delta and help you make
better trading decisions. Later I'm
going to do another presentation on
delta in in uh response to a question I
got about delta. So uh look for that in
a you know either later today or
tomorrow. I hope to get it done today.
So, like I said, you know, market's
pretty uneventful today. The nice trade,
nice trading opportunities. Um, during
the trading room, we're actually was
actually in the five years.
Um, and you I don't want to call it the
trading room. It's more of my education
center for uh users of my software,
right? you get my software, you get
access to my trading what quote unquote
trading room, but I I don't like the
term trading room because, you know,
that implies that you're there. You're
just there to get uh listen to me say
buy here or sell there. No, I I talk
about what's going on in the order flow.
So, I I don't want to mislead people
thinking that it's a place you can come
in and just sit back and follow my
trades. No, I I just I talk about what
I'm seeing in the order flow so you can
follow along and pick it up as well.
So, in the room this morning, um 9:00
you had the high in the five years. You
got your ratio with your divergence.
Again, I talk about this every single
day. And you know, if by now you
haven't applied it to your trading, why
not? I mean, uh again, you know, I just
show you these setups. Boom. Sells off
from his high right down to the low. Um
you do have the Delta Scalper giving a
buy here, but again, it's on a red bar.
You don't want to be taking it on a red
bar. You know what you want
is price action in the bar to confirm
that you know the market is indeed
moving up. Next bar comes in, hits the
low, then it starts its move back up,
but again is mostly sideways for most of
the day. Your point of control for the
day is, you know, right smack dab in the
middle of your profile. Now, you know,
earlier in the session at 5 in the
morning, you had a ratio bounds low as
well. You went from your high right down
to your low, though very tight range.
Your move only consisted of three bars
on a four range chart. Started, you had
a ratio down here. No divergence, but
you did start rallying back up again.
Delta scalper giving a buy. You rally
right back up into that high where you
get that beautiful sweet sell right
there on the top and you sell off from
your high down to your
low. The bonds, you know, the bonds
didn't really offer any decent
opportunities today. It
was I don't say a bit messy but you know
just not as neat and tidy as as the five
years
were. So you know this is the bonds this
morning. Um you know just even going
back you know back here to this low at
720 in the morning. You rallied up off
of that. You know it's not it's a ratio.
There's no divergence. And you know you
rallied up to your high. You started
coming off Delta Scalper giving a sell
there right off the high. You sold off
down into the lows. You got a
divergence, but no ratio. Um, you did
make a new low later. You got the
negative delta, so you don't have a
divergence. You do have a ratio, though,
and you rally back up. Um, yeah, I'd
prefer it with ratios, you know, and
divergences. You don't have it here on
on the on the bonds. Now, the buns, uh,
sticking with interest
rates. Uh, let me find my chart here.
The buns, where are you? Okay. So here
now again you
know being a
consistently good trader I don't want to
say being consistently profitable or
anything like that but you know but
being consistent in your trading means
that you have to take the trades when
they present themselves you know so here
early in the morning 2:00 in the morning
right buns open at 1:00 a.m. Chicago
time the cash market in the buns is is
an hour later 2:00 and boom right after
the open you get a ratio with divergence
sell okay what happens the market
rallies rallies back up to the high you
get another uh ratio no divergence
market still is not selling off and in
fact rallies makes new highs now there's
something in this bar that's actually
bullish here but um I'm what do I'm
keying in on is is this failed
divergence with ratio and again you know
some people will will see this and take
the loss and say, "Ah, you know, ratios
and divergences suck. Yeah, I just had a
loss." I mean, people are like that, you
know, they don't understand that trading
is is is a marathon. It's not a sprint,
right? You have to be in it over the
long term. You know, your trading career
does not revolve around one trade
and you you rally back up here. Boom.
Then you got another ratio with
divergence. Okay? You have a second
chance to get in. You know, you got a
lot of selling imbalances in here. 1 2
3. Next bar, you know, even though it's
green, you still got a nice selling
imbalance. You rally back up to the high
just like you did here. You had your
short rally back up and hit that high.
And probably you're thinking, "Fuck,
man. Why do I listen to this guy? He's
telling me ratios with divergences are
great trades." And here we're right back
up at our high now. It's it's against
me. Well, you know, again, you know, be
patient. You know, have faith in what
you're doing. Next bar down, next bar a
little bit lower, next bar rallies back
up within a tick of the high. And you're
thinking, "Fuck, man. Am I am I ever
going to get anything?" You know, but
it's not stopping you out. It's still,
you know, below your stop. Your stop is
just right above this high. You know, if
if you breach this high, there's no
reason to be short, right? So, you know,
it's not like you're placing your stop
five points above this high. No, it's
very tight. It's a four range bar, so
you got a five tick stop.
And then now, you know, a little bit
later, this is when the move starts. So
again, you know, you're getting short
somewhere around 12. Next thing you
know, you know, not next thing you know,
but a little bit later, you're trading
04. Boom. 02. You know, rally back up to
10, come back up, and just sort of hang
it around, make a move back down to 04.
But really, you know, you should be
getting this move down to at least 5 or
6.
I'm not saying that you'd hold it all
the way here until 4 in the morning when
it gets below double O, but it does come
down
and, you know, and just sort of hang
around off the low here again. You know,
you're not going to get short at 220 and
still be in this position at 4:00 in
the, you know, 2 hours
later. So again, you know, that that's,
you know, that's the thing is, you know,
stick with stick with it, right? I mean,
one of the reasons why traders,
beginning traders, new traders, so to
speak, fail is because they don't have
faith in what they're doing. They learn
something, they think it's great. You
know, they test it out and say, "Hey,
this is the way to go and I'm going to
do this." And they try it for a week,
maybe they don't take all the signals,
you know, they take some of them, and
they they try to overanalyze and take
don't take some, and those are the
trades that are winners, and they give
it up. You know, they think, "Ah, you
know, this is not the way to trade." And
next thing you know, a week later,
they're on to something else. you know,
you got to stick with it, right? You got
to stick with your analysis. If you
trust what you're
doing, you know, the I don't say the
money will come, but the good trades
will come as long as you have faith in
what you're doing and you know what
you're doing makes sense. I mean, you
kind you can have faith in what you're
doing, but you know, if if it you know,
if it doesn't work, it doesn't
work. Okay, so now we'll move on to the
Euro currencies. Um, let's start talking
a bit about the different currencies. So
here we got the uh Euro currency this
morning. Now this was interesting. We
rallied up at around you know just
around 5:00 in the morning. You have the
swing high here and you know you got
this move up from uh 14 all the way up
to
26 red
bar positive delta though. But next bar
delta sculper kicks off. You have a
selling imbalance in this bar. This is
around, you know, the 20 level 11220 and
we sell off. Um, you know, not a big
move. Um, you know, we sell off down to
around 12. Actually get a little bit
lower here down below 10. Um, then we
start working our way back up delta
scalper again in this bar. And, you
know, this this level is is very close
to this this previous level here.
Slightly higher, but you're seeing, you
know, here you had your swing high.
Selling came in right off this high.
Now, you rally back up to that level.
you got selling coming back in, you
know, with the Delta Scalper alerting
you that selling is is back in again at
at that same level. And what happens is
you sell back off down to down to the
level that you sold off before. I mean,
uh, to me that that was a pretty clear
one. You know, was that was a bit early
in the morning, but again, you know,
that was, you know, when you think,
right, it's it's a level, okay, you get
up here, people are interested in
selling it. You rally back up here, you
see a sign that people are interested in
selling it again. I mean, what what more
do you need? Um, as far as, you know, do
you need to be hit over the head with a
baseball bat to understand that, but
again, you know, maybe some people
aren't interested in it. Um, a little
bit later, you get uh 928, you get a
delta scalper giving you a buy here.
Next bar is up, next bar is down. You
got side by side point of
controls, and the bar in the second uh
sideby-side point of control is red, you
know. So then the next bar is is down as
well, lower point of control. So at this
point, um I'm not really looking for a
move higher with this delta scalper
because those signs are telling me that
this move is kind of stalled out and
maybe it's going to be heading back down
again. And you know, just sort of goes
sideways. Eventually it does sell off,
but again, you know, the sign that this
trade was not going to work out is right
here. These point of controls not going
any higher. In fact, they're just going
lower here. You got a new higher point
of control. This one is higher than this
bar, but then this one's equal. And then
this one's lower. So, you know, that
that's a sign that this trade is not
working
out. Then again, you make new lows, come
down into the new lows. Um, divergence
here that fails, got a new low here. Um,
you have a delta scalper buy here, but
it's a red candle. I'm not interested in
it. Delta scalper buy here is a green
candle. Now, I'm interested in it.
Right? Why am I not interested in on a
red candle? Well, it's a red freaking
candle. Why would I be looking to get
long when the market's selling off?
Again, Delta Scalper reads the delta.
doesn't um factor in price, right? It
just reads the delta and it's up to you
as a trader to make the decision. Do I
take this trade now or not? You know, if
you don't take it now because it has a
it's a red candle. Price action is
telling you the market's still moving
lower. Well, wait for the ideal
conditions. Ideal conditions is on a on
a green bar on market that's moving up
and you get it here. So, you know, even
if you missed it here, it's giving you
another entry right here. And this time,
you know, the market pops up over the
next few bars. um does come down, makes
new lows. This is around what time is
this? Just before 1:00. Here you got a
divergence, no ratio. Well, earlier you
had a ratio, sorry, a divergence with no
ratio. But here again, you got a
divergence with no ratio. Then you get
it in the next bar. Again, I say you got
a divergence. Look for a ratio to
confirm it either in the bar that the
divergence is in or the next bar. And
you got it in the next bar and the
market pops up here quite nicely.
Okay, the other next market I'll talk
about
is which one it was? Yen, I think it was
I want to talk
about. Okay. So, yeah, I'll just go back
to the high here. Oh, where was the
high? High was
here. Well, high was an Asian session.
Um, let's take it from the European
session high. Well, it's not really the
high. It came within a couple of ticks
of the high, sold off. Sort of just
grinding itself lower, then makes a move
around 5 6:00. Gets down towards the
low again. You know, you've got a you
got the market coming down here. Boom,
boom, boom. Deltas are getting I'll say
small, but you know, they're they're not
big. You got a stacked imbalance here.
Again, you stacked imbalance sort of
coming into the low. I'd rather not take
it. Well, the low is here at 7 and a
half. You can't see it's this red line,
but um this yellow line is the opening
price sort of coming down here. So, I
know there's selling going on. You know,
obviously, you know, I'm not surprised
to see a selling imbalance near a low.
I'd be more surprised to see a selling
balance near the high. Then, what do you
get as you start coming into this low?
Signs of buying. You know, that's what
I'm looking for. Signs of buying. I'm
not looking for signs of selling as the
market's selling off. I already know the
market is selling off. Instead, what I'm
looking for is, you know, a pulse in the
market, you know, that's got a heartbeat
that maybe there's buying coming in. And
you get it here with the Delta Scalper,
and it pops up over the next few bars.
It goes from um, you know, 18 all the
way up to 26 before dropping back down
around that area where you had this the
similar low. Again, single print here,
single print there, two lots here, one
lot here, uh, one or two ticks above.
And then again, you see the buying
coming in with the stacked imbalance.
Again, you know, would you rather be
taking selling a balance near the low or
buying a balance near to the low? You
know, we already know the market is
selling off here. Okay, I don't want to
be, oh, oh, there's a stack selling
imbalance, you get short. You I'd rather
have that sign, you know, much higher,
you know, way up here rather than have a
move from your high down to your low and
then you get a stack selling imbalance
and you get all excited because you got
a stack selling imbalance. Well, you
already know the market's selling off.
The market has sold off already.
Is the move can the move continue? Of
course it can. Can the move stop? Yes,
it can. Also, so you know where would
you ask yourself where would you rather
be getting short at a higher level or
after a move just happened and hey I got
stacked imbalance get short? I'd rather
not take that. I much be more interested
in this especially coming after this bar
here with a single print with a ratio
indicating price rejection and you know
this is a better trading opportunity and
the market was it do? It rallies again,
you know, from the 22 area up to 32. Um,
you know, 34, you know, later goes
higher. Then it's sort of you get this
double top here. I like this. You got 50
lots traded. Second time 14. I I always
like it when you get less volume. The
second time around, market comes off
again. Delta scalper gives a buy here.
This one just doesn't work out. Next bar
is red, lower point of control. Next
bar, lower point of control. This would
have just stopped you out in this in
this bar here. Um, again another delta
scalper buy. This one again
fails. Get down here. You got a um
ratio. Oh, sorry. No ratio. You have a
divergence. You got an imbalance here.
You got this green arrow. So, I know
there's some trap traders down here or I
hate that term trap traders, but traders
stuck um selling into this
low with the head fake and the market
rallies back
up. Then you get a stack selling
imbalance again. you know, I mean, is
this where you would want to take it? H
I'm not a big fan of them here. I said,
although it is after a little bit of a
move up, you know, rather than earlier I
showed you that one stacked imbalance,
you know, it would came like literally
right after a move down. At least this
one you got a little bit of a bounce up
and some selling coming back
in. And I think that was about it.
anything of interest in the in the yen
today. Um, what else do I want to look
at?
The Let's take a look at pound. I think
I got a pound
chart. I don't remember if there was
anything interesting in this market from
earlier.
pound is not, you know, it's something
people are interested in it. So, I I
like to talk about markets people have
interest in. Um, okay. So, yeah,
911 ratio and divergences here. Again,
doesn't get any more obvious than this
ratio and divergence. Again, ratio and
divergence. Market rallies up, delta
scalper,
sell, sells off, sort of goes sideways,
unfortunately. But again, this is it
right here. I mean, screenshot that and
just look for these types of
trades. Uh, beans, beans. I think we're
interesting today. I thought, let me see
if I can find the
chart. Beans, beans. Here we go.
Okay. So, you know, it was big beans
moved had a big move today.
Um, so you know, again, you know, 8:30
is the reopen 834 ratio with divergence.
You you pop up about 2 cents. Um, start
working your way down. You you got ratio
bounds low here. Point of control on the
bottom, which to me is normally a very
bullish bar and just comes right back
down. You got delta scalper on a dogee
bar again. you know, dogey bars I tend
to find to be in order flow um
relatively neutral in the sense that,
you know, I don't really like take
trades off dogee bars. Um then you get
down here new low divergence ratio in
the next bar. Again, market pops up
about uh you know, about 2 cents as
well. So, you know, you you've had you
know, already two ratios and you know,
one or two cents on the first one, you
know, good two cents on the next one.
Um, again, if you held it all the way up
through here, you get a little bit more
out of it. Market starts falling over
again. I mean, you know, you did have
this trade. I I thought this was
bullish, even though there's no um
divergence here. I could live with that
because there's to me there's some
supportive volume. I felt there was some
supportive volume in here. But again,
you know, if you get through this volume
like this, you start trading down
through it, you know, I do believe the
market will sell off in times like that,
especially in the beans. You see, you
hit these levels of of commercial
support. um that you know if that
commercial support gets blown out then
you know the market's just going to
naturally drop by a couple cents. So,
you know, you get up to the swing high,
you know, no ratio. You got a single
print up there. Market sells off. And I
I would love to say, oh, well, this is
actually this is the price rejector, but
I' I'd love to have something else up
there besides just the price
rejector. Get down here. No divergence,
no
ratio. Pop up a little bit again. Make
the move down.
Whoops. Lower. Lower. Failed
divergence. And you know, you know, this
time it's already 1:00. calculus market
closes in 15 minutes. You got a ratio
and a divergence again, you know, it
it's it's one of those things that's
tricky if you want to take a
trade going into the close because you
only got a limited time, you know, and
heaven forbid you lose your connection
and you're sitting on a position exposed
until the reopen. You know, granted, you
know, the market reopens, you know, I
mean, 6 hours later, it's not like you
got to sweat it out overnight like you
used to. But again, it's not advisable
to be taking stuff so close to the
close. But again, you know, if you were,
you took this one, you lost. And it
comes down here, point of control right
on the bottom. You know, I mean, if
you're a risk taker, you have four
minutes for the
close, you could write it up a couple of
pennies, you know, couple of cents
there. So again, you know, there's some
trades that worked out, some trades that
didn't. I would I would really love, you
know, and say, oh, you know, this delta,
sorry, this price rejector here is is
the trade of the day, you know, but
again, I I I like price
rejector as a backup tool, not
necessarily for a um a tool to take
trades off of myself. But again, that
that's me. That's how I use them. But
again know that was that was all you had
in the price rejector. You had one one
sign today right
here. You know all these things are are
tools. All the these things I develop
are tools. The delta scalper is more of
a I don't say trading system but again I
know people have built trading systems
around that uh Delta Scalper. So yeah I
haven't talked about S&Ps. We'll take a
look at S&Ps now.
I can find my chart. 10 range. We'll
start with the 10 range. Where the heck
are you? You know, very boring morning
in in S&Ps this morning. I we just
did make new highs later in the day, but
um get this off this. So, you know,
right on the low just before 5:00, you
had Delta Sculper giving a buy. You had
a divergence. You literally went from
your divergence on your high to your
low. But again, I'd like to have a
little bit something besides
divergence. And here you got the delta
sculper giving a buy. You rally up. You
get up to cash open and the market just
went sideways on you from 8:30 all the
way up to just before 10:00, you know,
9:45 when it started rallying, making
these new highs. And you know,
yesterday's value area high to me was
around this 38 level. So you know I had
that as as a target actually. You know
if if you look back on
yesterday's session you know to me the
value area high just sort of comes in
right here which is around 38 37 and
3/4. So and what happens you we get up
to 30 39 actually. Nothing really in
here tell me to get short. You know
really what I wanted to see was I I
wanted to see if the market could get
past the value area and continue on. You
know you're starting to break out of
yesterday's value. I mean, you rallied
all the way up through it, right? And I
want to see if you're going to get new
sellers coming into the market, right?
People with um deep pockets to cause the
trend to happen, and it doesn't happen.
It just sort of falls back in here. You
got a ratio with, sorry, you got a
divergence and a ratio in the next bar,
and the market just sort of hangs
around, goes sideways. Um you you make a
new high by, you know, what is that,
three ticks, and then you sell off. And
again, it's it you on a daily chart,
it's it's just a looks like um it's just
a dogey candle, I believe. If let me get
it up here yesterday, you know, right
here, you know, this is where we are in
the evening session. Um yeah, I kind of
predicted I say I predicted I was
expecting something like this to happen.
Um you know, this Monday where you had
the big up day, you didn't get any
follow-through the next day. you know,
you can't even take out the previous
high and you just sort of come back in.
And then on um
Wednesday, you know, sort of a nothing
day and Thursday again, sort of a
nothing day as well. So, we'll see what
Friday
brings.
Um take a look at crude really quick. I
don't think there was
anything in the crude, but um let's take
a look. I mean, crude had been moving
around
the last couple days. So, what do you
got here? So, you got this 8:00 8:18
delta sculper giving you a buy. Market
pops up a little bit, sort of comes back
down in there.
Um, you know, we start
rallying
later off your high. Delta Scalper
giving a
sell and Delta, you know, sells off a
little bit. Delta Scalper gives a buy
here. just goes
sideways and then we sell off late and
they got stacked in balance
there. Um sort of come down into this
low area. Sort of hang around here this
around 12:00. Delta Scalper giving a
buy. Um does pop up a bit. Delta Scalper
gives a sell here. Delta Scalper and
price
rejector. Market starts coming off.
Delta Scalper giving a buy here.
Whoops. This is already
230 though. Um, you know, just sort of
did nothing there. So, I mean, you know,
just using the delta sculper by itself,
you I think he did have a few
opportunities. Um, few trading
opportunities
there here off the high
here. You know, it depends. I don't know
what you would could have got on this.
Maybe would have broken even. Um, but
you know, then again, you know, this um
this one also a nice one here. So there
was some decent opportunities there on
the Delta
Sculper.
So was there any other markets? I think
I covered everything
here. What is this? Uh it's meal. Soy
meal again. Um, you know, soy mail is
not something that many people are
interested in besides me, but
um, this is this is this eight range
chart, but again, you know, I' I'd be
looking for the same things. You don't
have anything in here. Here's a delta
scalper kicking off, giving a
sell, and the market sells off quite
nicely here. You know, it's $10 a tick.
So, you know, a move from 296 to 295 is
um it's 100
bucks, you know. So, all got all the way
down to 293 and a
half. But again, you know, the the meal,
the soy meal is an interesting contract
to trade because u when we get into the
summer months, it tends to be a bit more
volatile and you know, there could be
some, like I said, it's $10 a tick.
There's can be some decent trading
opportunities in there if you're uh but
you got to be good. You got to be quick.
I say good. You got to be quick. Um cuz
it can move sometimes pretty quick on
you. Can move um you know from 295 to
296. Sometimes it can jump like that
pretty quick. So again, thanks for
watching this and be sure to subscribe
to my channel u below. Click the
subscribe button. And if you're
interested in learning more about
Orderflow, visit my uh website,
orderflows.com. And I I uh I'm always
running specials on the software. So
again, if you're interested in
Orderflow, visit my website,
orderflows.com, or uh subscribe to my
YouTube channel. At least you'll be
alerted when I post new videos. So
thanks everyone. Bye-bye.